okay so I'm very happy to be here so the
starting point for my research is that
people are by nature monochronic and
that means that people most people like
to start on a task work on it through to
completion before switching to something
else that's the way I am that's the way
most people are but we live in a world
in our digital age where we are forced
to be polychronic and that's because
people have multiple windows open
multiple screens people use multiple
devices lots of different applications
access to you know innumerable numbers
of people and types of information and
so you know we have this polychronic
lifestyle and and yet it's contrary to
what our nature is so I'm very
interested in how this kind of
polychronic lifestyle leads us to do
multitasking so when people think of
multitasking they think of people doing
two things at the same time and that's
not humanly possible unless it doesn't
require a lot of cognitive effort like
chewing gum and walking but if you
really want to do two kinds of
activities that require some kind of
cognitive processing it's not possible
multitasking is really about switching
activity it's very rapidly interleaving
of activities it's it's like time
sharing with computers so there's a lot
of work that has looked at the effects
of doing what's called media
multitasking and this is a little bit
different than switching back and forth
between different apps and different
sources of information but you know that
this work has especially looked at young
people teenagers college students and
they find that if kids are you know
doing their homework and you know doing
instant messaging or doing their
homework and watch YouTube they tend to
do worse on these tasks especially these
kinds of tasks that requires some kind
of goal directed sustained attention
also these people have difficulty from
filtering inference from stimuli that's
in their periphery in the environment
and so this leads us to ask the question
has medium multitasking led us to a very
different way of processing information
in this digital age now there are
challenges with measuring multitasking
and traditionally people have used
pencil and paper to measure it they ask
people you know how much to have you
multitask how much have you used
different devices but you know there are
some studies that show that people are
just notoriously bad at estimating time
and people can error up to about 30%
right being off with their estimates and
you can bring people into a lab and
there's lots of studies that have looked
at multitasking in the laboratory but
these don't really reflect real-world
behavior especially if you're thinking
about the workplace so you know you how
can you model career trajectories or
stress or conflicts with your colleagues
so my perspective and and this is this
is the approach that I take when when I
do research is that to really study
people you have to go where people are
and so rather than people bring people
into a laboratory and you know set up
pay you're creating an abstract model of
the world which has its advantages
because you can control variables but
you go to where people are and you
create living laboratories and that
means that you study people in their
natural environments and you try to do
it as unobtrusively as possible so
that's that's the approach I take to in
my research
it enables me to ask questions related
to multitasking things like how
fragmented is our attention when we work
with digital media and how do you
explain distraction with digital media
and how does it how does using digital
media affect our mood okay so I've been
asked well haven't people always
multitask what what is new about this so
you know I dug into the literature and
first of all no one has ever examined
people's use of digital media at least
to the level of detail that we have
where we we look at what people do to
the second but what people have done is
they they followed people around in the
workplace and they've looked at how
people distribute their time over the
workday so we have some basis for
comparison so if you look at the the two
columns on the right so this was a study
done by Hudson and colleagues this was
done at IBM in 2002 a study I did with
my student Victor Gonzalez in 2006 and
these were studies when personal
computing and email use were in
widespread use in the workplace and
these other studies were not so we have
some some kind of point of comparison
and if you look at these two rows the
amount of time the proportion of time
that people spent doing desk work versus
the proportion of time that people spent
in formal face-to-face scheduled
meetings you see a difference there and
this horn and Lupton study is a bit of
anomaly so if you kind of you know put
less weight on that study what kind of
trends do you see right you see some
trends so there's two things going on
the first is the proportion of time that
people spent at their desk nearly
doubled right
with the with the widespread use of
personal computing and email but also
people spend a much less proportion at
their time and he's formally scheduled
face-to-face meetings and if you put
these two together right we can infer
that a lot of the work that was formally
done in face-to-face meetings is
probably now being done at the desktop
through email through desktop
conferencing through instant messaging
through a lot of other channels so my
interest in going to where people are
and studying what people do in their
real-world environments is actually it
comes at a fortuitous time because we're
living at this time where there's this
revolution and the development of sensor
technologies and so I want to talk about
two projects that involved using a
variety of different sensors to
understand people's behavior as they
work with digital media the first
project is the health sense project
where we've been tracking information
workers so we've we've tracked over a
hundred workers to date over multiple
days about two weeks with a variety of
different sensors the second project I
will spend less time on but I'll just
say a few words and that's the
Millennial project and that was looking
at college students where we tracked 124
college students you know in their
normal college life and we tracked them
for seven days now the grand challenge
of doing this kind of work is that you
know if you if you were to do
ethnographic work right you get a good
sense of the how and the why of what
people are doing right you can take a a
deep dive into context and you can
understand the context when you're using
sensors you're getting different bits of
information disparate bits and you have
to somehow combine these bits of
information now it's pretty easy to
measure stress because
we have devices wearables that can
measure things like heart rate
variability in it and you can understand
stress but how can you understand a very
broad construct like workplace
performance or organizational
citizenship through sensor information
and at the very very end I'm going to
talk about a project I'm working on to
to try to get at that but I see that as
being the grand challenge so I'm going
to present results of a number of
studies that we've done but I want to go
through the measures with you so that
you get a sense of how we collected the
data so we measure stress through heart
rate monitors we we also now use wrist
wearables you measure what's called
heart rate variability we've also
measured electrodermal activity using
Affectiva cue sensors the newer version
is called impact akka we measure mood
and people's focus through experience
sampling I'll talk about that a little
bit later we met her face to face
interaction using scent cams that's this
this picture right here it's a very
small lightweight camera and it takes
continual photos about every 15 20
seconds and then you apply software face
detection on it to determine is there a
face present or not so you can have
infer at least if someone was near
another person and it has very high
accuracy in face detection we of course
measure digital activity by logging
computers and phones we do activity
tracking we have people wear acta graphs
fitbit's or wearables we and we use
those also to measure sleep and sleep
rhythms and then we give people a whole
lot of different demographic and
personality measures that we use to
correlate with our sensor data so I want
to start off by telling you what we can
learn
about people through very simple
information that we can collect if we
just look at temporal features of
computer and phone use just temporal
features what do I mean by that I mean
the time you turn your device on or off
what it's the average length of time the
dispersion did use it in a concentrated
period of time or over the day how often
you checked social media the rhythms
abuses a more regular usage or irregular
usage time of day so you put all these
features into a model and we find that
we can predict the Big Five personality
traits with a fair amount of accuracy
significantly better than chance just
simply in terms of temporal activity in
using devices so let's talk about
fragmented attention when people are
using digital media so we can start off
by just if we just long people's
computer activity we see and I should
mention that there's a lot of data
cleaning that goes into it huge amount
of data cleaning that so that we can you
know filter out all the noise and and
that's just a huge endeavor but just
looking at the median length of time
that people's attention is on any
computer screen before switching to
something else in the workplace we find
it to be about 40 seconds and that's
that's day in and day out right and
that's a that's a very short period of
time so you know I looked at this number
and thought that you know maybe there
are individual differences right not
everybody has short attention duration
some people spend longer some people
spend shorter and so we dug into the
and we hypothesize we found that these
are possible reasons that might explain
individual differences so neuroticism so
people people who score high in
neuroticism have a lot of thoughts that
are just kind of slowing through your
mind and this can interrupt your train
of thought and this could potentially
affect your duration of focus people who
are impulsive right there's different
dimensions of impulsiveness urgency is
this idea you just have to do something
you can't hold yourself back another
dimension is this this inability to just
persevere at something we hypothesize
that people who were stressed would have
shorter attention to racial and people
who had poor sleep the night before
because you don't have the cognitive
resources you need to focus and we also
hypothesized the the other way around
that if you the longer your focus
duration on the computer the higher
should be your self assess productivity
at the end of the day and we did find
that indeed neuroticism and
impulsiveness urgency were significantly
correlated very strong trends with
stress and sleep and a significant
relationship with productivity we did a
factor analysis and we find that these
three variables clustered under a factor
that we label lack of control and so the
way we interpret this individual
difference is that people who lack the
ability to control their actions these
are the people that have shorter
attention duration when working on a
computer so I'm going to try to unpack
this a little bit more but first I want
to say that you know you you save gee 40
seconds on the computer well maybe
that's not so bad if you're working
on the same project right probably
everyone here is an academic and when
you're writing a paper because we're in
the business of writing papers you'll
look on the internet you'll type in a
word document you go on email you talk
to colleagues but it's all the same
project so so what that your attention
is short on any kind of one of these
micro activities so this is actually
from earlier work that involves
ethnography where a student of mine
followed people around with a timer and
tracked every person's action to the
second with a timer and took notes about
context and found two things first of
all people work in an average of about
twelve different projects and we called
these working spheres sphere of work
just a little bit broader than the
notion of project because it could be
personal projects as well but clustering
all these different micro what we call
micro actions into their respective
projects we find that people spend about
ten and a half minutes on any project
before making a significant shift to
something else and for information
workers that's not a very long time
right because it takes I mean at least I
know if I try to do something it takes
me probably ten minutes just to try to
get started to go into depth if I'm
reading an article or writing something
and then I'm switching to something else
so let me talk about how people's
rhythms of attention is distributed
throughout the day
so the notion of attention focus right
this has been covered by different kinds
of constructs so people have called use
this notion of cognitive absorption
cognitive engagement mindfulness how
many of you here practice mindfulness
anybody okay
some people do Oh or the idea of flow
how many of you know what flow is okay
this is oh my god it's gonna be like a
six and majalis notion of flow where
you're so immersed in an activity that
you become completely unaware of the
passage of time okay so all of these
concepts have to do with attention focus
and then the flipside of attention
focused the way it's been treated in the
literature is boredom and so we know
that attention focus consistently is
associated with positive effects people
are happy when they're focused and we
know that boredom is associated with
negative effect right when people are
bored they generally tend to not be in a
good mood so if we look at this
dimension of attention and let's let's
think of it as engagement you know being
really engaged in something or not being
engaged at all in something this is
typically the way that research studies
have always treated attention but we
thought that perhaps there's an
orthogonal dimension that goes through
attention which has to do with the idea
of challenge and this comes from the
idea of flow because to be in a state of
flow it involves using your skill but
also being challenged at doing something
right without this notion of challenge
you can't be fully engaged so we came up
with this theoretical framework and and
let me walk through it with you so it's
the idea that if people are really
engaged in doing something and really
challenged we label it focus right it's
just a label that that we're using if
people are really engaged in doing
something and they're not very
challenged we call this wrote as in
wrote work and let me give you an
example playing solitaire right you're
really engaged in playing solitaire but
you're not really challenged by it or a
kind of mindless video game right where
you're just kind of really engaged in it
and it does involve any challenge at all
if people are not challenged to not
engaged we call that being bored and if
people are highly engaged and sorry high
highly challenged and not engaged we
call that frustrated again these are
just labels an example of frustration
could be a software developer who has to
figure out a bug and they're just not
really into it right but it's it's
challenging
so people were given these probes
throughout the day these are experience
sampling probes and they appeared on
people's computer screen and we asked
them to rate how they feel right now
this top part of the screen is Russell
circumplex model of mood where we're
getting a measure of people's mood at
this point in time and then down here
then it asks did you just have a
face-to-face interaction and then down
here we asked people how engaged were
you and how challenged were you and the
thing you were just doing we trained
people in this beforehand and they were
able to answer this probe in about maybe
2 seconds or so 2 or 3 seconds people
were given these probes about 18 times a
day the irony does not escape me that we
interrupted people 18 times a day but we
got terrific data so remember that
attention is associated with positive
effect okay so we find that people are
actually happiest when they're doing
rote work this kind of mechanical
mindless kind of work that's what makes
people happy right in in the workplace
people are less happy when they're
focused and then consistent with all the
the research people are at least happy
when they're bored
yeah is that given that you said that
people switch kind of areas they're
working on every 10 minutes is that make
it harder they get to data about what's
going on so those were these kind of
effect attentional states kind of stay
consistent oh okay so we actually had
this kind of hybrid heuristics that were
using to introduce these probes so we
were particularly interested in
capturing mood and attention like right
after Facebook use and right after email
and so we we drew no no no that's right
that's right and then when people unlock
their screen we would ask them and then
if they had an interaction we would know
about that interaction and when they
submitted these probes
we would get timestamps so we could sync
that up with all of our other data so
that we could try and make sense of it
but that thank you for the question so
this is what the rhythm of people's
attention focus and different
attentional states look like over the
course of the day over our participants
and there's a few things about this that
I find interesting
first of all people's peak focus is
about 11 o'clock in the morning late
morning and about 3 p.m. so it's not
like your focus is continual throughout
the day being bored is
somewhat of a uniform distribution sort
of but what I find interesting is that
people don't come to work ramped up and
ready to go but it takes some time to
ease into the work right to get into
their work right there they don't hit
the ground running when they come to the
workplace yeah so these are information
workers in a high-tech company located
in the Pacific Northwest we put a lot of
thought into that and we kept going back
and forth should we kind of normalize
depending on when people came and then
we decided that because there's because
interaction is an important component of
the workplace we would actually do this
according to the actual time so if
someone you know a few people came to
work at 7:00 but you know most people
were in the workplace nine ish or so
right but we kept going back and forth
so we normalize it as to the first you
know and call it first second third hour
but you know six of one half a dozen the
other but we thought maybe it's better
also because most people do tend to eat
lunch at the same time so we thought it
would be better maybe to sync up by that
way if you you see the same rapper or
because everyone else is there yeah
interesting yeah that we have not looked
at them but that's super interesting to
look at yeah so I want to talk about
work that was done with Alex Williams
who was an intern at MSR and Alex was
very interested in seeing if he could
devise a way to get people to
reattach faster to work in the morning
and to detached from work at the end of
the day and there's just a lot of work
that shows how if people don't detach
from the workplace it creates stress and
bad mood and you know that it affects
people's health and and well-being and
so he designed switch pot which was a
chat pot that had there were actually
two conditions so people used switch but
first of all they they worked as they
normally did and had their computer
activity logged and people we were asked
we gave them surveys two kinds of chat
pot designs the first asked was tasks
centric and asked people in the morning
what do you want to work on today and
the emotion centric approach a different
set of subjects between subjects design
was how do you want to feel today so get
people to either focus on the task or
focusing on the emotion and at the end
of the day for detachment the task
centric chatbot ask people what did you
work on today again work work centric
and emotion centric how did you feel
about work today
it's like having your therapist at the
end of the day so we there were 34
people over to work weeks and I mean the
results were interesting in that the
reattachment chatbot irrespective of
whether was task or motion centric it
received a positive evaluation but
people with the task centric dialogue
actually used more productivity apps in
the first hour of the day productivity
apps are things like Word or Excel or
visual basic studio or anything that's
related to work yes that's right
but it was not sustained right we the
effect was was short-lived it was only
in the first hour so I I think that was
informative
the detachment part of the chat but got
it sort of a met evaluation but people
in the evening actually did send
significantly fewer emails and there was
no difference in whether it was the task
or emotion centric diet like and over
overall people they assess their
productivity at the end of the day and
they assessed their productivity higher
but there's there's a lot I think it's
an interesting first step but there's a
lot more things that that can be studied
with respect to detachment and
reattachment okay so now let's talk
about distractions okay so I've been
looking at interruptions for a long time
and one of probably one of the most
surprising things I found is that people
tend to self interrupt or what we call
internal interruptions almost as much as
they get externally interrupted by some
observable source right external
interruption is a facebook notification
or colleague comes into your office or
the phone rings you can point to some
external stimulus that causes the
interruption an internal or self
interruption is is really interesting to
watch your your as the observer you're
watching someone they're typing in a
word document and they suddenly stop and
they check email or they stop and pick
up the phone right there's no observable
or explainable reason reason for the
observer for this behavior now we looked
at our data and we divided the data into
our leave time windows and we looked at
the relationship of external and
internal interruptions in each of these
our longtime link
and we found something really
interesting that when external
interruptions waned what happened was
that internal interruption started to
kick in right and it's as though I mean
the way I interpret this is that if your
people are conditioned to interrupt and
if you're not getting interrupted by
some external source you interrupt
yourself because people are just
conditioned to have short attention
spans and they're going to they're going
to cut off what they're doing change
their activity one way or the other if
not from an external source than from an
internal source so that's my my
interpretation of the data now people
have studied interruptions and there's
this assumption that people in the
workplace they work really hard and
they're really focused and then along
comes a distraction like Facebook
notification they go to Facebook and
then they get really bored but we
wondered if maybe it's the other way
around maybe it's possible that people
first get bored or they get into a
particular attentional state that makes
them susceptible to a distraction that
makes it easier for them to be
distracted so we looked at some common
time types of interruptions based based
on our data it turns out that 40% of
interruptions are from some form of
workplace communication email which is
primarily work-related at least in this
particular company face-to-face could be
either it could be work-related or
social and Facebook is primarily social
interaction and to give you kind of an
overview of how people spend their time
in these workplace communications we see
that with Facebook people average about
times a day that they check Facebook
email about seventy four times a day
actually the high person in our sample
was something like four hundred thirty
five times a day checking email but they
spent it they tend to spend relatively
short periods of time so people check
Facebook but they only spend about the
eighteen seconds and then go back to
work and email they average about thirty
two seconds and then go back to work so
frequent checks and very short periods
of time so this is the way that we
looked at our data so we had this
experience sampling probe we had the
time stamp we had how people assess
their attention in terms of engagement
and challenge and we looked at the
duration of time that people spent in
facebook face to face and email
face to face by the way were this is
based on the the sense cam data we
looked at various windows of time five
minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes and they
were consistent so I'm just reporting
the 10 minute results and of course we
had to control what people were doing
prior to the probe right so here's what
we found we found that when people were
in a focused state of mind
they worked significantly longer on
email when people were either bored or
doing roadwork we found significantly
more face-to-face interactions and when
people were doing rote work we found
significantly longer Facebook use so
there seems to be a relationship between
people's attention 'el state and what
their they're doing after so it took me
six years to find a field site that was
willing to let itself be cut off from
email for a period of a
and actually the way I got that field
side is is a really funny story that I'm
happy to tell sometime maybe over beers
but finally got the the field site and
we had people wearing heart rate
monitors to measure heart rate
variability stress we logged their
computer activity we measured them for
one baseline week and then they cut off
email for a period of the week and we
hypothesize that their stress would go
down
yeah well that was they knew and it
could have changed it we we don't know
how much had changed but after I show
you the results I'll say a little bit
more about that so when people were cut
off from email they did focus
significantly longer on any computer
screen compared to when yep compared to
the baseline when when they had email
the flipside of looking at the data it's
sort of like the other side of the coin
is the number of switches per hour and
people switched about half as frequently
when when they didn't have email and
that didn't necessarily have to be the
case I mean might think well of course
they took away email they won't switch
as much they could have switched as much
with all of their other applications
they were using right but they didn't
yeah they didn't have slack so that they
only had email yeah and they they were
information workers and it was an
organization on the East Coast not the
Pacific Northwest stress was
significantly lower you're you're
looking at this number and saying wait a
minute but this is a higher number and
that's because heart rate variability
the higher the variability the more
relaxed people are and that's because if
you're really relaxed the least little
stimulus is going to make you jump and
affect the variability and if you're
really stressed the variability of your
heart rate that comes the time between
consecutive heartbeats
it's very regular right you're in this
kind of fight or flight syndrome and so
we've found people were more relaxed
when less stressed when they didn't have
email down to James to your question we
actually expected that when email was
first cutoff people would become more
stressed right and then we would see a
decline but it was all over the map so
there there was no particular regularity
in people's behavior so if people were
affected by the cutoff you know it's we
we can't say but we we can say that we
did see this for some people we we saw
this abrupt change when it happened
switching oh right so first of all there
there was a significant difference
between baseline and cutting off email
so if stress went up there there was
still a significant difference people
were allowed to contact other people but
they just couldn't use the email and
that was another interesting thing was
that people could have just walked down
the hall to talk to someone in person
but they just didn't for for many of
those cases they didn't some people did
one person this is really interesting he
reported that his manager would always
give him these little tasks to do and he
couldn't get any work done cuz he'd get
an email from his manager that he had to
respond to because it was his manager
when the
email was cut off his manager could have
simply walked in and delegated
face-to-face these tasks but he didn't
he just stopped so there was that you
know that's an interesting case of email
being used to delegate work so we asked
yes unfortunately we didn't right and
that's something that I wish we would
have done right so we did interview
everybody but we I wish we would have
and you know what I suspect what my best
guess is that there would be no change
that's what I think so we asked the
question how does what's the difference
between social interaction that's online
and offline offline meaning face to face
what makes people happier in the
workplace right it's an important
question because mood and positive mood
in the workplace is associated with
motivation and quality of work and
productivity so by online activity we
looked at Facebook because of this
particular organization Facebook was the
primary online social interaction tool
that people used and we looked at two
different time perspectives and the
first perspective is comparing people's
mood positive effect at the time the
interaction occurred now how many of you
think that people work happier right
after doing a face-to-face interaction
compared to Facebook how many of you
think happier after face-to-face how
many of you think people were happier
after doing a Facebook interaction
nobody how many think there was no
difference okay the answer is face to
face so people work happier the second
time perspective we looked at is
people's happiness at the end of the day
we asked them to reflect back over the
day and you know how
how happy are you you know you're
leaving at the end of the day this is
important because there are carryover
effects of workplace mood to personal
lights at home now how many of you think
people were happiest at the end of the
day the more face-to-face interaction
that they had during the day okay how
many of you think they were happier the
more time they spend on Facebook that
day how many of you think there was no
difference how many of you don't know
fair fair enough so it turns out that
the answer is Facebook that the more
time on facebook the happier people were
at the end of the day now this was
puzzling for us so we went back and dug
into the data and here's what we found
we found that there was this very strong
correlation between using Facebook on
that day and reporting that they were
engaged in their work and so here's the
way that we interpret it that if you're
really engaged and work you know
Facebook offers you this way to move in
and out to take a break under your
control you can move in and out right
seamlessly under your control the last
thing you want to do if you're engaged
in your work is to have a face-to-face
interaction because you are a prisoner
of that interaction right you're working
really hard on something and you have to
do this face-to-face interaction there's
a greeting ritual and the interaction
and the parting ritual and you can't
gracefully just leave so we think that
facebook offers this what we call
grazing behavior when people are really
engaged in work so we wanted to see what
would happen if we blocked distractions
and there's a lot of commercial software
out there that people can use to block
distractions and but it had not been
empirically tested so we decided to do
that
we did a field study we had 32
information workers used a commercial
software called freedom measured five
days of baseline and five days when they
had their online distractions blocked
people could choose what it was that
distracted them and what they wanted to
block and this is just a rough
approximation of what was blocked most
of it was social media but they also
blocked news sites eBay shopping sites
and so on so using the cognitive
absorption scale which is a well
validated scale of attention focus we
find that with this blocking software in
use for a week people's focused
immersion in an activity significantly
increased temporal dissociation means
you're so immersed in something you're
unaware of time passing that actually
decreased that means people became more
aware of time there was no difference in
their feeling of control which really
surprised us their enjoyment decreased
while we took away their social media
and there was no difference in curiosity
so we interviewed people afterwards and
the reason that they reported white
focused increased first of all we
removed attention residue so when you
take care of when you look at Facebook
or do an email and you come back to your
work role you still have this residue
from that interruption right this this
kind of part of your attention is still
focused on that interruption and that
was removed but we also stopped chains
of distraction people reported you don't
just check facebook or check a new site
on the internet but you go into this
rabbit hole of distractions and we took
that away so then we looked at the data
to try to figure out why didn't we see a
difference in control and it turns out
that from the interview data there were
indeed two different groups that
merged people who had high self-control
and people who had low self-control and
what we looked at we had measured the
Big Five personality traits and we found
that people who through the interviews
came off as having high self-control
scored significantly higher in
conscientiousness and significantly
lower in this impulsivity trait of lack
of perseverance we had some some
validation from the interview data and
then we looked more into the data and
using the NASA TLX scale which is a
measure of mental workload which
includes the measures of stress and
mental effort we find that people in low
self-control you know there was really
no significant difference in their
mental in their workload when they used
this blocking software but strangely
enough people who were in the high
self-control control group had
significantly higher workload when we
took away their online distractions and
so you know in going back into the
interview data to try to explain it it
seems that you know these are
conscientious people and they don't take
breaks they just worked straight through
right they could have taken physical
breaks and gone to the coffee room and
they didn't they just stayed there they
didn't have their online distractions to
you know to take a quick mental break
under which they would have control and
were able to get back to work all right
one person missed her shuttle at the end
of the day which had never done before
because she was just working straight
through there are opportunities for
improving work experience from this data
first of all thinking how to balance
rote and focused work if we know their
rote work is associated with people
being happy we have to think about how
we can balance that throughout the day
and also scheduling work based on
attention patterns mealy so do this just
as
overall view but there are personalized
patterns of attention that could be
looked at there are times when people
can be very focused and other times not
we can design interventions to increase
focus reduce stress and improve mood and
I have a project working on that now and
we can block distractions for people who
are have low control right so it's
important to consider individual
differences so I was going to talk about
the millennial generation and I'm
running out of time but I will just
present one result here and that has to
do with sleep because college students
are notoriously bad with sleep and so
what we did was we looked at you know
there's a lot of studies that look at
the effect of using technology on
people's sleep that evening and we asked
the reverse question how does people's
sleep quality the night before effect
what they do with digital media the next
day right and here's what we found we
looked at sleep debt we figured it
doesn't make much sense to just look at
a single night of poor sleep because
habits are hard to change but what
happens when poor sleep accumulates over
days right then you accumulate sleep
debt right you get more and more tired
and we found a significant relationship
that the more sleep debt that people had
accumulated the more time they spent on
Facebook the next day and that's easy to
explain because Facebook is lightweight
does not involve cognitive resources
right so it's something easy to do if
you just lack these these mental
resources
the faithful 41-7 once coefficients here
so it was Facebook to reach that there
was seconds so first which they're
spending four seconds longer on Facebook
something like that
I'm sorry that I I think it was second I
think I think but let me 2016 let me get
back to you because sleep debt was not
measured in terms of seconds I'm trying
to think about like you know observing
absent eyes the sense like if I'm one
standard deviation sleepy yeah exactly
oh well that's good but I will look it
up because you caught me and I can't
remember what but I I mean I remember
the that okay so now I'm gonna put on my
psychologist hat which which I really
like to do and you know how do you
explain all this and so this is the idea
this is what I think about you know
there's a long history in psychology
that it's very consistent and talks
about how people strive to maintain a
kind of inner balance right this kind of
balanced emotional and psychological
state
Hippocrates talked about with with the
body harmonious balance Gestalt Fury's
talked about the law of pregnancy where
you have this unified theory of
perception my favorite psychological
theory of all time is Kurt Lewin's field
theory which is that our ultimate goal
is to reduce tension in our lives and
every
actually do it's designed to reduce our
tension and of course you you know
cognitive dissonance theory and so you
know this is an idea that I work with
that maybe people adjust their use of
digital media in order to achieve and in
turn on balance when when they're
working at it so you know when things
become too stressful perhaps they switch
to something else to try to balance this
out very quickly I want to talk about
what I'm currently working on the Tesori
project very excited about this it's
it's the same idea of using sensors to
predict a workplace experience and to in
particular organizational citizenship
organizational deviance task performance
stress to the point that it gets to
burnout and our target is to measure 750
workers over a year to date we have
about 250 people enrolled but I hope
we'll get close if not achieved 750 and
we have a lot of different sensors that
we're using you know wearable devices
beacons so that we can look at a
location phone agent to see how people
are using their phone and we're also
looking at people's social media use and
I do want to stress we are very
concerned about privacy of our
participants and you can look at the URL
for more information this was work was
done with the collaboration of a number
of really incredible people that I
really need to to give them credit for
this work and I would like to thank our
sponsors but also our participants thank
you
[Applause]
yes but first introducing internal
interruptions I'm gonna give some
thought about like interventions like
like people teach the spinners are like
give them like background music etc like
can you like you like combat the need
for internal destruction before they sew
so - all right so if we think of an
internal interruption is mind wandering
to think of some way to kind of prevent
that mind wandering so we haven't done
that right that's that's a I would say
that's a grand challenge that's that's
gonna be really hard to do but would be
really great if someone were able to
achieve that because that it's really
it's hard to measure mind-wandering but
if there's a way that you can you know
find a way to get people to focus and
prevent it that's that's the million
dollar question you think they're going
to do some internal interruption
interceding some other less bad internal
interruption so you're still doing
something but you know it's not quite as
yeah that's interesting so more closer
related to the context of your work so
what about the difference between
volitional and non volitional
interventions like can we intervene
without people even realizing they're
here should we do it because since I'm
part of the challenge here is is that
not engagement but it is a challenge of
life in the developing you have it but
maybe we need to develop interventions
that might not even like depend on your
will to do it but maybe just force you
like never yeah
I love you to change your breathing by
changing some kind of like maybe your
temperature in their room such that you
start bringing out different paints
something like that that you don't even
yeah I just keep working yeah I think
there was just a lot of room in this
area for for experimentation but but I
really love that direction yeah yeah
yeah just you mentioned that people feel
better when they do sort of road work
I'm just curious to think reason on a
patient and concerns about that how we
can keep people I guess engaged at work
and happy but still I guess not you know
totally replaced by nice operations
right so they're there does need to be
some intellectual type of work you can't
just have people doing this kind of
mindless work I said I think it would be
really interesting to think about what
the right scheduling is right the the
roadwork can offer a kind of respite
right focus is also associated with
stress we found so you can't I mean you
don't want people to just focus
continually throughout the day could you
really want to have some kind of balance
right Automation might move the balance
right to the other way where people are
just doing this kind of rote work on the
other hand you know people are arguing
that automation will free people up to
do the intellectual work right and let
the machines do the rote work and and
maybe this is what you are getting at
that your would people be less happy if
we're taking the road work away I don't
know that's a good topic for a study
[Applause]
you